[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARJITA SETHI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to "Public
Speaking Pro Tips"
with Speechless presented
by Google Developers.
We help people turn the
mundane into memorable.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Challenges into insights.
ARJITA SETHI: And presentations
into performances.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Today we're going
to help you merge your
profession with your passion.
ARJITA SETHI: And the way we do
that is with an exercise called
vennspiration.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Vennspiration is visualized
with a Venn diagram intersecting
your talk topic with something
you love doing outside of work.
ARJITA SETHI: And what
merges is a new way
to give your talk more energy
as well as making it more
universal for your audience.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: So
let's demonstrate.
Arjita, first let's
have you tell me
about a project
you've worked on.
We'll time box this
for 30 seconds.
ARJITA SETHI: OK, I
was a physiotherapist.
And as part of my job, I worked
as an antidoping official
at the Commonwealth
Games and ensured
that all the athletes
were not cheating and not
using any harmful substances.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
OK, now let's have
you talk about something
you're passionate about outside
of work.
ARJITA SETHI: Well, does
it matter what it is?
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Not
really, as long as it's
something that you love doing
and it's something active.
ARJITA SETHI: OK, I guess
I'll talk about teaching.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Great.
30 seconds on the clock,
ready when you are.
ARJITA SETHI: Well,
I love teaching.
It's one of the most
innate desires of my life.
Because every time I teach
something and the students
sit with me and there is
a sparkle in their eyes,
it helps me understand
that I contributed
to the growth of that person.
And I love it.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Great.
Did you notice
anything different
between the two talks?
ARJITA SETHI: Well,
it was more fun
to share my passion with you.
And I felt like the
subject matter was easier
to talk about.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: I
could sense that.
I felt like when you described
the brightness in those kids'
eyes, I could feel you
be brighter as well.
And that's actually what
happens to most people
when they get more excited
to talk about themselves
and their interests outside of
work than their actual jobs.
ARJITA SETHI: And
this is a problem
since most people
have to talk at work
in front of fellow
employees and clients
about business and not pleasure.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: So that's why
you should combine the two when
you get the chance.
It breathes new
life into your talk
and makes it easier for
audiences to relate.
ARJITA SETHI: OK,
so what do I do now?
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
First, start by saying
physiotherapy is like teaching.
And from there, make
connections between the two.
You'll be surprised at how
much they have in common.
ARJITA SETHI: OK.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: One
minute on the clock.
Go.
ARJITA SETHI:
Well, physiotherapy
is like teaching because
every patient is just
like a new student.
Just like you assess
a patient, that's
when we assess students to
see the level of the learning.
And the treatment protocol that
you build for every patient
is similar to the syllabus
for every student.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
How did that feel?
ARJITA SETHI: ARJITA
SETHI: Honestly,
that felt really good.
I never thought to
connect the two topics,
but I can see how this would
be very valuable as a speaker.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Exactly.
Using similes and analogies
are really powerful.
For example--
ARJITA SETHI: This deadline
is approaching as fast
as a bullet train.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Exactly.
I could picture the train, and
that helps drive home the point
because metaphors are visual.
They help make something
complicated easier
for an audience to
imagine and understand.
And now, you know it only
takes a couple minutes total
to see where it can lead.
You can pair any talk
with any passion or hobby
for endless combinations.
ARJITA SETHI: It's like
playing a slot machine.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: I like that.
Vennspiration is like
playing a slot machine.
I see what you did there.
ARJITA SETHI: I'm
a fast learner.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And I'm
sure you are as well.
Now it's your turn.
Go ahead and make your
own vennspiration video.
ARJITA SETHI: Take
your video and post
it to social with the
hashtag #DevelopYourVoice.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And remember,
check the description
below for links from Google
Developers, Women Techmakers,
and more tips from Speechless on
how to think like an improviser
and develop your voice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]